jenna hello what's up oh my gosh you
guys oh wow
there's a lot of stuff happening today
today we were gonna shoot a video and
then i was like tyler we need to just
redo everything we basically ripped the
entire
shooting room apart we're making
different sections we now have a podcast
section
he says wait he says
hold on we have an eye like this is new
look at it
we're working out all the kinks here but
i'm very excited to show you guys what
we
actually did today this is something
that we've been waiting for this is the
road caster with all of the accessories
for our podcasting we are officially
officially podcasters now because before
we were borrowing the equipment and it's
gonna be good because we're not gonna
have to keep setting it up taking it
down setting it up taking it down
this is gonna be way better for
efficiency as well as our mental health
yes because it took so long to set
everything up we'll show you guys here
in a second basically this is like my
unboxing area then we basically swing
this light around
and then we're ready and set for
podcasting okay thank you to rhode for
hooking us up they got us all set up to
be
actual professional podcasters let's
start with the actual road caster itself
okay okay i'm gonna make us some room
there's so many goodies
i love our new setup i'm so hyped about
it look how cool the set looks
we've got all kinds of cool stuff back
there guys
[Music]
this is extremely exciting one of my
favorite things about podcasting is
pushing the buttons on the road caster
pro
and since this is ours now we can set
those up to be whatever we want we can
have our own sounds
so this is the whole system and each one
of these are the various inputs
so you can also have this plugged into
your computer which is really cool
because when we're doing
virtual guests we're able to hear them
through here through the computer and
you guys can also hear them there's also
a bluetooth
connection so we're able to bluetooth in
from our phones and there's four
different inputs
that you can input back here through xlr
and these are the buttons that jenna
loves
you like them too okay yeah but you're
like super into that so you can add like
custom sounds or if you guys listen to a
podcast before we have like the clapping
it's like yeah
this other sound is like the sexy sound
so this does have a micro sd card which
is really cool because you don't need a
computer you can record directly here
this is your entire podcast setup is
here you need nothing else
except the microphones of course but you
don't need a computer to record
that's right everything records directly
convenient it has this
big record button which is red when it's
recording
yep green when it's not there's more
there's a lot more there's a lot more
okay let's open up the microphones next
these are the broadcast quality dynamic
microphone
called procaster do you know why because
we're pro
casters and the audio is incredible so
these are super exciting
it comes with this very nice little
baggie oh
a sticker i love the roping at the same
time
what a nice little travel bag this is
very nice it's a heavy dude
okay okay microphone check
we definitely need shotguns because
we're always just hitting
the table this looks like the cup holder
that we have on our uh super 73 bikes
this is nice oh this is
a very heavy duty solid nice quality oh
my god oh my gosh
look how sturdy my earbud is do you
think
that we can use the extras in the
meantime as this is an incredible cup
holder
careful wait okay yeah that's good oh be
careful
i already opened one and set it at our
desk because i wanted to just make sure
that it was going to work with the desk
that we have over there
we can just use this so this will just
clamp right on the desk
caution there it is there it is spring
loaded people
super spring loaded very
loaded look at that it's bending this is
a good workout
i'm shredded after three pumps that's
great
so i think we have everything unboxed
now let's go set up our
podcasting desk so we're basically going
to just take the shot and it's going to
be like
are they able to see in there if you
look over there will they see where
they're going to be
that's where you guys are look at that
that's where you guys are going to be
[Music]
so this is the podcast set up the whole
idea for this room was to
make it so that we have several
different sets my goal was to keep
everything as confined as possible so
this is what we've got
the podcast set is here and the way that
tyler was able to configure this light
it's great because we just have to well
it's a little bit of maneuvering
and then we just can swing this right
over like this and guess what
we are set for our second set
we might add a top down here we also set
up an option for a top-down station
right over here as well so we have this
little light here this is like a little
eye lights
and it's so small it's the small version
it's a smaller newer version of those
big tube lights that we have
back there in the back speaking of the
back so this is also a shelf that i had
actually downstairs in my kitchen and i
just put a few of my favorite things
some of my favorite books and this was
actually from
john when we did an unboxing of this um
that was a while ago
and this is an original 1984 mac that i
also
did an unboxing of but i actually forgot
about it i never posted the unboxing
do you remember that that was a while
ago that was like last year oops
so that's the room so far this is kind
of version
45 at this point but i feel like this is
version one of this new room setup tyler
also did we talked about that before
that you blacked out the windows with
garbage bags
i don't think we did talk about that
tyler's like let's block these out but
look at this you did such a good job
the reason we did this is because we can
now completely control the lighting
because we would be shooting at all
times at the day
and then when we were shooting after the
sun went down we're like man it looks
really great in here
we now have controlled lighting and i
also have somebody coming to paint this
wall
i think i'm gonna do i don't know if i
should do a dark gray or just go
for the black i have to decide i gotta
decide because they're coming tomorrow
stay tuned
[Music]
jenna hello no close your eyes okay
jenna get ready
i i've kept you blindfolded for the past
two weeks
you haven't seen the new podcast that
open them
oh my gosh it looks so
good the lighting looks incredible the
table
the microphone the wall oh my god
it's so nice she's already seen it we've
already shot two
episodes here but this is the the sets
the reveal
you've already seen it but i love it i
love the look i think it looks
incredible i'm super hyped
um but yeah if you guys want to check
out the podcast you can check it out
anchor dot fm
slash same brain we also now have an
instagram and twitter we've had it for a
while we just haven't updated it but
that's usually updated we have a youtube
channel
so i'll put all the links in the
description you guys want to check that
out but the new set looks great
and now all we have to do is figure out
how to
streamline this process to make it a
little bit quicker good luck with that
see you later bye
we're going to need a new bench yeah
this thing is hurting this
sucks we're sitting on a bench and it's
not good and it's rocky so i'm like my
butt
hurts okay cool bye see you later
delete everything